turning to the derrick chauvin murder
trial the fired officer's lawyer used
body cam video of angry bystanders
to try to counter witnesses who
testified that he acted
outside police policy as jamie yukis
reports the defense
also pushed its theory that george
floyd's health problems and drug use
caused his death we warn you this may be
hard to watch
derek chovin's defense attorney played
this clip for james ryerson the special
agent leading the investigation into
george floyd's death
listen to mr floyd's voice
[Music]
did you hear that yes i did did it
appear that mr floyd said
i ate too many drugs yes it did the
prosecution
quickly followed up playing more of the
video and re-asking ryerson what he
[Music]
heard
having heard it in context you're able
to tell
what mr floyd is saying there yes i
believe mr floyd was saying
i ain't doing all drugs a central
argument for chauvin's defense
is that floyd's death was caused by drug
use the prosecution
is not refuting that floyd took some
drugs but is arguing
chauvin's restraint was still the cause
of death cbs news legal analyst ricky
clement
the defense says it was his heart
condition
plus his ingestion of drugs on that
day so the prosecution knows that this
is coming
and they better headed off at the past
which was what they tried to do today
the defense also came back to one of its
central arguments
the effect the crowd had on chauvin's
actions when questioning
lapd sergeant jody steiger you are an
officer and you're engaged with the
suspect
right and somebody else is now pacing
around
and watching you and watching you and
calling you names
and saying this could be viewed by a
reasonable
officer as a threat as a potential
threat correct the prosecution asked
specifically about the crowd that was on
the scene
that day i did not perceive them as
being a threat
they were merely filming and they were
most of it was their concern for mr
floyd
ricky clement tells us chauvin's defense
team is doing its best to try to create
doubt in that
one juror who could cause a hung jury
but it's a long way from here to closing
arguments
the hennepin county medical examiner
will testify later this week
his office classified george floyd's
death as a homicide
saying he died of cardiac arrest
complicated by restraint
and neck compression tony but jamie you
make the right point it could come down
to
one juror that's all it will take for
the defense to get what it's looking for
thank you very much